indonésie monde des îles indiennes
habitait comme il se doit par des
indonésiens dont le type le plus pur se
rencontrent chez les batak de fûts matra
d'une taille au dessus de la moyenne ce
qui ne se voit pas encore chez des
enfants
ils ont ce qui se voit dès la naissance
le teint cuivré les cheveux noir le
visage ovale les pommettes forte les
yeux horizontaux et bien fondus dans un
schéma tracé l'île la plus occidentale
de l'archipel de la sonde
elle a été découverte en 15/100 8 par le
portugais se guérira et la cinquième ou
du monde par sa superficie
les enfants ils font des rêves ils
placent haut dans le ciel comme leurs
cerfs-volants
et puis là comme ailleurs il y a des
traditions d habitude les coutumes et
les enfants vont à l'école
bien sûr mais ils y apprennent ou pas
tali la preuve dit étudie le
traditionnel jeune jack c'est un art
classique de la lutte qui est pratiqué
est connu partout en indonésie cependant
il existe des variantes de cet art et
cette méthode que vous voyez
actuellement sur ces images est propre
aux populations de mme yvonne kambo
chambre de sumatra beaucoup d'adressent
d'agilité et le chou place
une bonne leçon et maintenant passons à
l'action et il est impossible de le
poignarde aucun doute ses chaussures
pour fait des jambes ses jambes
un corps et ce corps se promène dans le
job gars c'est une des plus grandes
villes de l'indonésie l'aah se trouvent
des achalandages sympathique c'est aussi
ta job gars que se tient l'université
on est moteur musique comme on peut
c'est une bulle qui respecte ses
traditions telle cette danse qui fait
partie du folklore du pays elle a pour
nom dans cerenis est considéré par les
indonésiens comme le plus beau fleuron
de leur folklore
dans les temps anciens seuls les
princesses de son royal avait avant leur
mariage
le droit de la danse et
et les indonésiens nous dirons que les
arbres leur pays ressemble assez dense
et nous remarquerons nous facilement
combien les mouvements de la série marc
ressemble à ces mouvements de
marionnettes marionnettes qui depuis des
siècles appartiennent tallard indonésien
et ont leur origine dans la religion
elles datent de l'époque où la
population est en majorité de religion
hindoue
c'est pourquoi arjun à l'esprit hindous
traditionnel de la vérité de la bonté en
est-il presque toujours le principal
sujet
tandis que le boxeur chinois et le
capitaine de bateau portugais sont venus
beaucoup plus tard
et puis il y à des performances dont
vaud chinoises qui sont accomplis avec
des marionnettes appelé va jean rajaona
voulant dire au monde
près de georgia existe bobos du lait
facile de s'y rendre par ce moyen de
locomotion
c'est un lieu préservé plein des
vocations
il a été construit il ya plus de mille
ans par des colons venus de l'inde
là existe un temple ce temple on y
accède par de vieux escaliers
il est construit selon la mode d'un
stupa géant stoupas veut dire cloches et
les stupa vont decrescendo jusqu'à la
taille minuscule d'étagé en étage car
elles représentent les étapes
progressives de l'illumination de
bouddha tandis qu'il contemplait dieu
au chemin après avoir atteint le
septième et dernier degré de
concentration
là nous on est aveuglé par la révélation
le bouddha h f pour lui et ses
descendants spirituels le pas final qui
le conduit à la paix
cette construction en forme de cloche
représente le détachement de l'homme à
l'égard du monde matériel et sa
recherche de l'unité avec le maître des
cieux
non il ne joue pas sachez si vous y
allez un jour que cela porte chance de
toucher la main du bouddha à silence à
stocker cette eau prince gotham ap l'on
doit ces richesses il les a laissés pour
l'amour de dieu et de l'humanité et les
jeunes gens se rendent souvent là pour
solliciter la chance avant
d'entreprendre grand travail celui de
devenir un homme
et l'âge d'homme conduit souvent au
mariage c'est ce qui arrive aujourd'hui
à nassir il se rend à la cérémonie vêtu
de son costume traditionnel de minhang
abo
voici ces charmants le fiancé ratnam
extraordinairement par cette coiffure
évoque la roue d'un banc
à
m
quand la cérémonie s'achève le plus
vieil homme du village béni les jeunes
époux et selon la tradition leur
prodigue des conseils de toutes sortes
il leur fait aussi prendre conscience de
leur réalité et de leurs responsabilités
présente et future
et c'est la mère du jeune époux puisque
là-bas la mer occupe la place centrale
la place clé dans la vie de famille
c'est donc elle qui invite les amis à
partager le repas de noces
non
et la cérémonie célébrée selon le plus
ancien radis sion s'achève par la danse
du plat et de la chandelle qui a pour
nom dans stars hyper in les deux petits
plats que vous voyez sont hippie ling
sur lesquels les chandelles allumées
sont disposés cette danse n'a lieu que
pour des fêtes précise et seulement ça
pète sont situés à la fin des moissons
certains mouvements ont des
significations propres ils représentent
des symboles il exprime par exemple le
repiquage du riz la récolte
l'édification des murs
d'autres mouvements stylisé mime la
femme en train d'effectuer ces
préparatifs de fait le bain après tant
sa chevelure et son maquillage
voici un monde en marche où les
traditions les modes de vie anciennes
sont pleinement respectés
on
non
m